So we do have primary elections today.
Three of the four scheduled primaries are
happening today despite what is going on with
Corona virus, Arizona, Florida, Illinois and
Ohio were scheduled to vote.
Now Ohio Governor Mike DeWine, who's a Republican,
announced.
Polls are closed.
The Ohio primary is postponed and tentatively
for June.
Although who on earth knows at this point
what our world will look like in three months,
it's hard to imagine what it will even look
like in 10 days if the current infection numbers
continue.
This is do or die for Bernie.
I mean, if Joe Biden picks up more than an
additional hundred delegate lead on Bernie
tonight, you know, Bernie has a hypothetical
path right now, although it's unlikely it's
already a longshot.
If Bernie falls another hundred delegates
behind tonight, it's essentially done.
So we'll look at national polling, we'll look
at delegate counts, we'll look at state polls
and figure out sort of what to expect tonight
in terms of the delegate count going in.
It's a hundred and fifty one delegate lead
for Joseph R. Biden, junior.
Ninety four to seven.
We believed that tonight we were going to
have a total of 577 delegates available.
That's Arizona, Florida, Illinois and Ohio.
Florida, of course, the big prize with 219
delegates.
Ohio postponing their primary.
So the 136 delegates out of Ohio will be saved
for another day, so to speak.
Now, in terms of the polling, as you know,
nationally, Bernie Sanders has hit a ceiling
of about 36 percent.
And nationally, Joe Biden is leading the last
dozen or so polls, most recently by as much
as 29.
Bernie did manage to get 38 percent in one
in the latest Economist YouGov poll.
But the numbers looking very, very solid for
the former vise president.
Looking state by state at polling in the states
that were scheduled to vote today in Arizona,
Joe Biden averaging plus 18.
In Florida, Joe Biden averaging plus thirty
nine.
Illinois has Biden at plus twenty nine and
a half.
And Ohio, which again, has postponed their
primary as of now until sometime in June.
Who knows?
Biden was up 22 and a half.
I'm not even going to do delegate estimates
for what it will look like at the end of the
night.
I mean, I think we all know that with these
margins, if the margins hold.
It's a very bad night for Bernie Sanders and
a huge debate over whether anybody should
be voting at all because of what, you know,
we have on the one hand and we'll get to it.
Donald Trump yesterday saying officially for
the country, you shouldn't have more than
10 people together.
You kids shouldn't be at schools, restaurants
and bars should close.
And we may have to continue some version of
this up until July or August.
And then meanwhile, Florida, Illinois and
Arizona have huge crowds of people, presumably
assuming people are showing up to vote.
And we will we will find out in just a few
hours congregating and doing all of the things
Donald Trump says they are not supposed to
do.
There was the idea that maybe the debate between
Bernie Sanders and Joe Biden on Sunday night
would change the numbers.
It didn't.
We got we now have post debate polls and the
numbers are essentially unchanged.
It was scheduled to be a debate with an audience
in Arizona because of the virus.
The change was made to do it in a studio with
just the candidates and three moderators with
CNN in Washington, D.C..
And again, the you know, I think that there
were a lot of people e-mailing me, expecting
Biden to implode, unable to speak because
of his supposed dementia, which has been a
story being pushed not only by people on the
right, but also some people on the left.
And the problem is the expectation was that
Biden would so miserably implode.
Biden just had to be coherent for the debate
and he was unlikely to really be damaged.
And that's what happened.
You know, there were some disagreements, disagreements
about how to deal with the virus there.
I think Bernie's strongest moment during the
two person debate on Sunday night was when
they started talking about Social Security.
But again, it didn't seem like it was going
to make a difference.
I tweeted that I didn't think it was going
We now have debate, but post-debate polling
and it has not made a difference so far.
So we are going to know very soon what at
least in Arizona, Illinois and Florida, Democratic
voters who choose to go have decided.
The other idea that's been floated has been
because old folks are more at risk if they
get the virus.
Old folks.
May disproportionately stay home, which will
hurt Biden and help Bernie.
That was floated last week as well.
Now, of course, in a week a lot has changed
when it comes to the virus and to people being
told to stay home.
We'll know within hours.
At this point, I don't know that it makes
much sense to speculate beyond these ideas.
We will have a results live stream starting
tonight at 8:00 p.m. Eastern Time on Twitch,
YouTube and Facebook live.
I hope you'll join me.
We will take in the results together in what
are very, very strange times at this point.
Quite frankly, I for me, it's been every morning
I wake up sometimes a few minutes before my
alarm, sometimes with my alarm.
And there's I would call it a five second
period.
It's probably more a fraction of a second
where I forget what's going on with current
coronavirus.
It feels normal for just like a fraction of
a second.
And then I remember that that's not the case.
And we've shifted around our entire production
to to adjust to trying to stay away from people
and crowds.
I am, you know, mostly just home.
This could go on for months.
We don't know.
But there is that split second in the morning
where it just feels normal.
I'm wondering if other people are experiencing
that.
These are I think we will all remember.
Living through this, those that do and of
course, tragically not everybody will, those
that lived through this will certainly remember
this for the rest of our lives.